before we start this video just want to
take a moment to say thank you so much
to vessi for sponsoring this episode
i'm really excited to have found vessi
because they are a great
everyday shoe i love how versatile they
are and you can wear them both in summer
and winter climates and they're also
super comfortable so when you're on your
feet the entire day you'll never get
tired at least
i've been wearing them to do errands
walk the dog be on set
go to the office and i'm especially
excited for when we start traveling
again because they're lightweight
and they're easy to style with anything
also they're 100 waterproof if they get
dirty you can just rinse them off and
wear them right away
besties truly are an everyday sneaker
that can keep by the door and it's great
how they are sustainably made with less
material waste
less water waste and no animal
byproducts which means
yes they're vegan check them out in the
link below and use the code jubilee to
get 25
off and enjoy the episode
on the way here we noticed that there
was an outback yeah the steakhouse yeah
the steakhouse
i'm vegetarian and she's vegan oh well
then this
might not work out
[Music]
this is my friend lily we met in college
we attend college together you're
constantly recreating yourself i would
say
the most recent iteration of that looks
like these really beautiful rugs
and she even made the earrings that i'm
wearing right now this is izzy
and the fun fact that came to my mind
was that she wore a duct tape dress to
improv nationals
which i think is pretty cool because she
made it herself at the end of the day
we're both
pretty open to most people and like
what matters is a level of empathy and
the ability to listen i think that's
something that like holds true for us
[Music]
hi guys
a lot of people the hands are clammy but
like in a cute way yeah
on a ideal first date it would probably
be like a beach day you know have like a
little picnic
and then after that it hit like a live
event show like enjoy some music after
what kind of music you guys listen to
everything but country on the way here
we noticed that there was an outback
yeah the steakhouse yeah the steakhouse
that's thank you
well i'm vegetarian and she's vegan oh
well
then this might not work out but no we
can work with it we were thinking that
we would check in first on yelp mm-hmm
get that free blooming onions and then
maybe ask for some
vegan options i guess i like the
planning though yeah i think it'd be fun
if we went to a show we're both
musicians so you could come to our show
what music do you play we say cyber a
very cyber
for our first day we would take you to
either a concert if you're feeling up to
it
a music festival and we would just dance
the night away yeah
and maybe after we could go to like a
karaoke bar
my boy could serenade you it could be a
duet
we'd first want to plan out the night
before so you guys aren't stressing
about anything
you're vegan and vegetarian so we could
go to veggie grill probably go surfing
so we'll go from san diego
and then probably bond with mimosas then
we go to the beach
and then something we like to do is uh
stroll around ikea
i've never been to ikea we take you
flying to napa valley
because he has a private pilot's license
and then we're going to go to a vineyard
over there
and i'm a musician and i'm a film major
so we can play some music we can
do some you know cute videos
[Music]
i don't know if i would want my first
date to be ikea i'm gonna say that
i'm so sorry it's tough yeah i think you
know we'll find our ikea buddies
i'm gonna keep going you're gonna keep
going we don't know how to surf i would
love to learn but
maybe not as a first date but it was so
nice meeting both of you i think that
we only got like one sentence out so but
i mean it is what it is
okay hold on whatever you i'm so sorry
we we try to buy with a lot of people so
i think at some point we probably
probably would have clicked but i guess
we'll never know
okay i'm a little scared of planes so i
don't know if i could do the plane date
what i'm getting a little nauseous and i
have to take my tram i mean we can
totally drive
we should drive i'm so sorry it's
totally fine
it was a little short-lived but it was
definitely fun unfortunately
[Music]
there you go hello see i'm matt man too
much to say
honestly i think before i never had a
best friend i'm telling you that
i think as guys many times when i'm
authentic with each other right i think
for us that's something that's really
valuable
you want to just build each other up and
he does a good job of just
encouraging me with his thoughtfulness
his caring his kind heart thanks matt
i would honestly call this man a
visionary and a dreamer
he wants to make a change and a positive
impact he's also a visionary he
produces music his dj's like all around
the world he's extremely talented
produces music and djs too not around
the world but around the city
he really will like listen to you not
just like hear the words that you're
saying he'll listen and like feel what
you're saying
biggest weakness are his grammar
he'll allow you to see the world in a
different way allow you to hear things
differently and it kind of changes your
perspective on how you see people and
how you see the world
yeah he's got like this fly hair
and a cool grill it's got hella views on
youtube
the artist and he's super loyal he's
from florida and i don't know if it's
because he's from florida he's got that
southern hospitality
that's my bro for life you
the best for know friend
i think maybe xander his friend was
talking a lot about how he's like a
really good listener and like will
totally listen to you wholeheartedly
and that's just something that i value
about izzy in terms of
energy like matt came out here and he
was bouncing in the same way that lily's
been bouncing this entire time
okay you point to the left i'll point to
the right okay
it was okay i didn't take it too hard it
didn't take it personally you know yeah
i really tripping as long as these racks
ain't slipping
you know what i'm saying
[Music]
hello again hello hello
wow hi again hello hello meet again
are you guys both from california oc
yeah california orange county so
southern california born and raised
despite being in southern california i'm
definitely like a winter person
i don't know if that says anything about
me it says a lot yeah it does okay
yeah i'm a summer person there we go
best of both worlds
what are you about to get what grade are
you in what are you dreaming you're both
juniors and you're majoring in what
about business
oh my gosh okay nice thing okay i read a
lot
and uh hang out with this guy a lot so
we both do those things sometimes yeah
yeah like read books
right next to each other in the same
room books yeah
you read to each other you tuck them in
right no that's just you have to take
your homies
you have to tuck your homies in yeah
i think we would go as the way we're
sitting correct
possibly yeah i would think about that
we don't know
i think so no i i think the way we're
sitting as well
okay so just just a height thing yeah i
would probably
switch yeah sides totally
okay here you go it changes things a
little bit wow this is definitely yeah
we really want to stress just a
stress-free day for you guys so we would
like
hit you guys up the night before give
you some itinerary but it's still loose
you know
and then yeah like we said we want to
accommodate you guys and so vegetarian a
vegan
go to your favorite place veggie grill
and we're also just so spontaneous
if we like sprung upon you guys like a
water balloon fight how would you react
that would be exciting i love we both
special thing about this we both like
being kids
yeah i'm a 12
okay a recent development in our lives
includes going to the local court
and playing something that like
resembles pickup basketball with each
other
how do you guys feel about that
basketball
court this guy has an insane hook shot
yeah my skyhook is actually
no way oh my god
are you ready yes
okay two
two i was gonna say two but you said it
before me but i was there with you
but two yeah that's what i was gonna say
yeah yeah hi hi
same seats yeah yeah so
you guys are back out here because we
chose you guys how do you feel about
that
um honestly i thought we were going to
be eliminated immediately
when you said you're vegetarian vegan
but it was like funny like you guys
carried on the bank right
you weren't like oh my god no you were
like well you were like
yeah and that's what mattered and i
don't eat there that often
i really don't it's okay it's okay if
you do if you guys want
to exchange numbers i'm down i'm not
gonna say we're done
okay i mean okay yeah okay totally
cool it was really nice
i like your tattoo do you have any oh
thanks i do have something
oh my gosh
blue cheese it's about 10 racks
10k you know these are fee styles not
freestyles